vous étiez aujourd'hui et bien dans une
réunion avec la première ministre
Elisabeth borne qui a communiqué
d'ailleurs sur cette réunion en disant
que elle cherchait des convergences avec
les sénateurs socialistes est-ce que
vous en avez trouvé sur la suite de ce
quinquennat elle est plutôt employé le
mot de compromis que de convergence plus
raisonnable je pense je sais moi j'ai
répondu à Madame borne qu'il n'y aurait
pas de co-construction donc il était
hors de question que nous construisions
ensemble des projets de loi du
gouvernement la séparation des pouvoirs
ce n'est pas la confusion des pouvoirs
elle a acté très très tranquillement par
contre le fait que nous puissions
examiner plus en amont les textes du
gouvernement nous permettre de mieux
faire nos auditions d'avoir plus de
temps pour travailler et faire
correctement notre travail de
parlementaire elle en a pris acte aussi
et l'exemple qu'elle m'a donné ce qui
est juste c'est qu'il n'y aura pas de
session extraordinaire en septembre et
donc nous aurons le temps d'examiner a
priori le premier texte qui serait
présenté en première lecture au Sénat
sur la politique migratoire je souhaite
beaucoup de courage dans la matière
parce que je je pense que là les
clivages vont être très forts et alors
donc ce que vous dites si vous êtes
d'accord avec cette méthode plus de
temps pour préparer les textes de loi
sur le fond vous n'êtes pas convaincu
par la politique à venir du gouvernement
donc clairement je vais dire j'ai posé
des questions entre madame borne est-ce
qu'elle était prête aujourd'hui bon à
prendre finalement ses responsabilités
vis-à-vis des ménages les plus aisés en
matière éventuellement d'un ISF qui
pourrait être climatique au regard de la
crise énergétique la réponse est non va
ton taxer les super profits entreprises
dans cette crise énergétique la réponse
est non va-t-on ouvrir les droits
sociaux pour les moins de 18 pour les
moins de 25 ans la réponse est non bon
voilà je veux dire qu'il n'y a pas de
changement de fond le cap reste le même
c'est bien une politique libérale qui
est devant nous et que les gens
combattre et donc concrètement les
textes en faveur du pouvoir d'achat qui
arrivent cette semaine au Sénat si ils
ne sont pas amendés les sénateur
socialistes ne les voteront pas nous
aurons des amendements le RSA à 18 ans
je vous l'ai dit ne pas voter la prime
Macron lancer l'idée d'une grande
référence salariale le SMIC à 1500 euros
nous allons porter ses amendements je
mesure que leur chance d'aboutir est
très très faible mais néanmoins nous
porterons la voie finalement des
salariés parce que la prime Macron qui
sera dans l'article 1er la loi sur
pouvoir d'achat et pour nous un non sens
c'est une rupture même avec l'histoire
sociale et économique de notre pays
merci beaucoup
[Musique]